grab your spandex and listen up because
we have an all-new season of American
Horror Story and think story is here to
take a deep dive into each episode I'm
not gonna waste any of your time so
let's get right into it we were in 1970
baby at beautiful camp redwood which if
you've seen the trailer doesn't turn out
so well we're introduced to these two
who we saw in the trailer and this dude
and his lambskin condoms because you
never know when a girl will be allergic
to latex we hear the clanging of mr.
jingles Keys who we've seen from the
trailer is supposedly the main bad guy
this season yes we can confirm that
we're in the middle of camp season and
these teens are camp counselors notice
also the grain in the film here which
isn't shown in the 1984 scenes so if you
ever see this grain we're likely dealing
with a flashback that mimics the style
and feel of an old 80 / bonus surge in
goals working at Camp redwood and as
soon as this girl takes her top off
these two are dead which is officially
the worst cock-block ever here we get
our first glimpse at the hand of mr.
jingles and the sound of his keys which
we see here briefly and here's a shot of
me watching the final season of Game of
Thrones
now the creator's make an effort to show
jingles cutting off this campers ear
serial killers have been known to take
tokens of their victims so expect these
ears to come into play later on in the
season we also see the extent of the
massacre and that jingles walks with a
limp now this makes sense since many of
the early slasher villains like Jason
Voorhees or Michael Myers walked very
slowly so making jingles unable to run
is keeping in line with that tradition
but what is most revealing about the
scene is the exclusion of Leslie
Grossman's character who we saw in the
trailer as being in that very cabin the
night of the massacre we'll meet her a
bit later on as the owner of the camp
Margaret Boothe now in my trailer video
i theorize that her character is my
number one pick of being the real or
surprise killer and just this morning I
got a message from Twitter user Kael
harden who expanded on this idea that
jingles is actually coming back to exact
revenge on Margaret and
possibly to save the other campers the
theory goes that he was framed for the
massacre and that Margaret was the real
killer and so far it's making a lot of
sense she's a religious nutjob who
decides to reopen the camp where she
almost died her affinity to remain pure
and clean would also give her motive to
kill the philandering teens at the
beginning of the episode which coincides
with the plots of many 80's horror where
a killer goes after horny teens now we
have our look at the new intro titles
which can also give some interesting
clues about the season notice the four
by three aspect ratio which is similar
to those of VHS movies and the 1980s
music video style and retro graphics we
also get a few shots of the camp but
what I think is most revealing in this
is the inclusion of the ear but also of
this ear with sound waves going into it
we've already seen that jingles likes to
cut off ears so pay attention to this in
episodes to come
speaking of jingles we also get this
quick shot of keys and the 80s were huge
with montages so we get a quick 80s
dance montage with our favorite son of
Satan who is looking more like the son
of Richard Simmons
here we get introduced to our main cast
xavier montana ray Chet and Brooke but
it looks like both Brooke and Chet are
going to hit it off
Montana remarks on Brooke ah gling
Chet's mound as I suspected in my
trailer video she might be into girls
herself talking about how great Brookes
butt is but considering she used to date
Xavier it's likely she's bi Brooke
however isn't here to hook up it looks
like her character will be that of the
stereotypical slasher virgin a trope
which I'm sure Ryan Murphy will
hopefully subvert in the lobby Xavier
remarks about the Night Stalker a serial
killer on the loose who apparently
stabbed someone 40 times almost
decapitating his victim
Chet introduces himself to Brooke and
she creams her pants we learned that
Montana quote rear-ended Xavier well in
traffic which is a very graphic double
entendre Xavier is a method actor who
trained under the real acting guru
Stella Adler and Ray met Chet at a party
where Justine Bateman was who was an
actual actress known for the 1984 show
tales from the darkside
summer is gonna be crazy in LA due to
the Olympics and Xavier suggests they
all get a summer job as counselors a few
hours away from the city
while Montana writes her number on
Brookes arm in case she's interested
while at home Brooke removes her earring
yet another reference to ears when she
is later attacked by the Night Stalker
he somehow knows she has jewelry and
although his attempt at killing her is
thwarted he says I will find you Satan
will show me the way considering how
much last season focused on Satan I
wouldn't be surprised if there's some
crossover here also considering how we
know la has a Satanist cult that was
seen last season who knows if they'll
show up rather than stay at home with
the Night Stalker still on the loose and
knowing where she lives
Brooke ventures off with the gang and
Montana gets a little close we learned
that Chet was about to be an Olympian
when he was disqualified for drug use
and for you young kids out there that's
a Polaroid [ __ ] I'm old at a roadside
gas station we meet this lovely
character Edie according to his nametag
and yes he is Patrick Swayze's brother
notice his ring of keys here which mr.
jingles will later take for
Xavier checks his voicemail on the pay
phone with what appears to be a jealous
ex-lover saying he's going to find him
could Xavier Zechs be the night stalker
which leads him to Brooke while
seemingly lost on the way
Xavier runs over this guy but what's
mysterious is the fact he says he can't
remember his name
now we don't know if this is the result
of him getting hit or if it happened
prior since as Xavier notes he already
had dried blood and cuts that happened
to him before the accident the hiker
also says a menacing line you gotta
believe me I tried so expect this to be
expanded on later the counselors arrive
at Camp redwood where we meet Margaret
and we're told that the kids are
supposed to arrive in the morning but
first things first they got to get this
hiker to the infirmary there they meet
Rita who tells them she used to work at
Hawthorne hospital now might just be
coincidence but the Hawthorne School for
exceptional young men was where Michael
Langdon was trained and where most of
the events of apocalypse take place they
lied Arita saying they found the hiker
on the side of the road when they
actually hit him Margaret then shows
them to their quarters we get a few
shots of the lake and an introduction to
chef birdy who was around when Margaret
was just a camper this is our first
indication that Margaret was indeed a
camper before she reopened the camp
after quote one bad apple ruined it a
reference to mr. jingles in the massacre
Margaret tells them that the girls
shower in the a.m. and the boys in the
p.m. and we've already seen in the
trailer someone peeping at one of the
male's showering who I surmised due to
eye color as being either Xavier or
Matthew Morrison's character who we'll
meet in a bit after Margaret shows them
to their cabins we learned that she's a
religious zealot who fights quote the
Lord's fight against filth
she stood alongside Charles Keating who
was a real-life anti-pornography
advocate famous for his crusade against
Larry Flynt and we learned her husband
died leaving her with a fortune which
she used to reopen the camp and make it
a godly place for children to escape
very convenient for her husband to die
and leave her with all this money around
the campfire Rita tells the counselors
about the camp redwood Massacre which
happened 14 years ago and we get a
little bit of an origin story for mr.
jingles
aka
Benjamin Richter apparently he was a
Vietnam veteran who collected the ears
of his kills and became somewhat of a
groundskeeper at Redwood when one day he
snapped murdering all the female
counselors there was one survivor
however Margaret who says through the
power of Christ was able to leave her
body while she was having her ear sawed
off as to not make a sound she hopes
that by reopening camp redwood she can
turn the dark memories she had into
something bright and happy the hiker
awakens in the middle of the night and
checks himself in the mirror to find out
that he has also lost his ear now this
has happened before jingles arrival so
there's obviously someone else
perpetrating these acts Brooke decides
to check on the hiker or so she says I
can't help but feel she's in that
infirmary for a different reason
she's startled by the hiker who tells
her that the phone lines are down
because it wouldn't be an 80 slash if
they weren't and when she tries to
comfort him he seems confused that camp
redwood has reopened back at the cabin
were introduced to everyone's favorite
Glee teacher Matthew Morrison
he plays a character named Trevor who
was cut from a Jane Fonda video for
being too distracting it's
skinny-dipping time and Trevor in
Montana are already breaking Margaret's
rules they're interrupted by an
impending storm and a pair of spooky
headlights
now we haven't seen jingles arrived yet
he arrives later when it's raining so my
guess is that this is someone else
likely Margaret keeping tabs on them
were then introduced to dr. hopple and
what appears to be a scene straight out
of 1978 Halloween with a patient mr.
jingles having escaped three hours
earlier he killed an orderly and escaped
taking his glasses and keys with him we
learned earlier that Rey is also an
orderly so it will be interesting if
there is a connection here hopple
inspects the cell to find a newspaper
clipping about the reopening of camp
redwood with Margaret's pitcher circled
in blood jingles is going back to
redwood to put an end to it's only
survivor or perhaps to seek revenge if
the theory is correct back at the gas
station ed works on a car and take a
look at these delicious hot dogs and you
know if you're underneath a car in a
horror show this isn't gonna turn out
well mr. jingles come
lately destroys him and takes his keys
also note that jingles has killed two
people so far and hasn't taken either of
their ears as tokens shet goes full roid
rage after seeing the opening of the
Olympics and his pissed he isn't there
he throws a crushed beer can a tray who
gets a massive cut and reader refuses to
help because she's the worst nurse ever
nurse I'm here for the kids
Brooke looks after array and they share
a little moment here so if we go by the
horror trope that the virgin character
will survive it usually means her love
interest is one of the first to go so
who watch out ray Brooke says she'll
look for some iodine and bandages when
she notices the hiker hanging out with
the sound and image of what appears to
be mr. jingles watching her we don't see
the perpetrators face here which leads
me to believe we're dealing with the
second killer someone who is motivated
to keep the hiker quiet but this
character has a limp and you can hear
the keys so it's either one of three
things Margaret trying to keep in
character jingles trying to say Brooke
from the real killer or I'm just
thinking way too hard on this and it's
simply jingles trying to kill her as
Brooke runs I love how it's juxtaposed
with the lighting of the Olympic torch
she tells the other counselors what she
saw and when they go to investigate they
find nothing
also Montana has the worst shield ever
and look who's there to usher them back
to their cabins Margaret who just so
happens to be in a similar raincoat to
mr. jingles Brooke seems to be the only
one noticing this phone ringing and
wakes up Montana who we find sleeps with
a switchblade you know that switchblade
is gonna come back Brooke ends up
answering the phone when we hear the
clang of mr. jingles keys and see the
arrival of the Night Stalker this is
accompanied by Brooke asking the person
on the phone who it is and if you listen
carefully you can hear the response
seyton we know the Night Stalker is a
follower of Satan so this makes sense
that's it for my episode 1 breakdown
guys
I am super pumped about this season I
think it was a fantastic first episode
set up a lot of stuff but I want to hear
what you thought about it in the
thoughts below make sure to give the
video a like and subscribe with the
Belon as I plan to do breakdowns of
episode you can also follow me and send
me theories to my Twitter app pink story
whitey
until next time remember daddy loves you
very much